o lado sensual do que quem fala é o dar
que seja muito bem vindo já mais um
vídeo deu o estrago de uma notícia muito
importante o gt assim que saiu para o pc
cinco anos depois o jogador tal é judeu
no haiti aí o jogo é um jogo
o cara é mais hawks papo depois deste
mini desabafa vamos lá então jogar april
sim porque ainda não tenho gta mas
quiserem digitar já agora aproveita não
é de chuvas foi que tem com os
comentários porque nem deixe assim pode
ser que o compre uma peç 4 jogo a visto
que escalar o jogo lá se o primeiro
então tem mais a lei diz não sei
o ex-procurador shows que joão souto em
ipanema gta5 ok primeira missão enquanto
augusto tem de um magneto não está
descontrolado meu deus não é manter o
homem no centro o meu deus do céu você
precisa aprontado que tem uma estrutura
da polícia de choque mais funky cops não
tem um corpo que berlim é um copo d'água
eu estou uma doida ok estacionei dia 5 e
só que vou tentar fazer um coisa
se tu não sabes nada acerca do gta 5 ou
se não tem nossos jovens mas a natureza
o final não quer saber eu já joguei na
minha infância israel o ulsan andressa
muito não se jairo e ela pra casa de
ópera da tuna vila missão bicicletas
também pergunta número 1 qual é a
localização do do oeste office 2004
vamos ver o que é como eu digo mais de
clientes voltaram a rondar os magic
esquece por isso não está certo é que
agora estão número 2
qual é o ano é o filme favorito do
maicon dos santos dantas tem cuidado e
ninguém os vai magoar e eu sou rico e
miserável eu sou na dos casos de mil
coisas por dia e eu acho que parece ser
esta
vamos perguntar a minha perna na perna
sabe a resposta
não acho que eu tenho que superar a
perna pelo estado não falou do rock e
vamos ver o que o mpe o bicho é bom ter
o meu destino porque eu quero fazer isto
meu esta não é essa que é o destino da
maioria dos que aqui
ana pergunta número 3 qual é o nome do
gta 5 qual edson da qual é a música de
entrada de introduzir 7 a 5 de junho em
lei o canto san andrés não issues fúria
dos andres não é do gt as infâncias não
me enganam de rock de los santos é isto
e eu sei que nos gts em que estão
lotados
o mall é o tuba pronto já murcharam
dinamizar as coisas como elas devem ser
analisadas não é de rock faz me lembrar
um gás que faz rock é igual a antes
connection nossa gestão em conexão com o
rock do o santos faz sentido agora um
artista chamado ou noel canto o xanthi o
flamengo dizer ou notebook um anel e
está a trilha original não há depois
disso o encanto das 12 mil e teme que o
uso do papel
ok vamos pra que chegue a hora é esta a
resposta certa se conseguir por teres
conseguir um não faz sentido então isto
porque se houver agora sérios nem fará o
seu papel é saudável da ganda boca por
conta do número 4 quando é que a
rockstar north norte é porque é a uma
sua escala quando é que a rockstar
cônsul desenvolvimento do grande salto
15 anos lá ir embora pra frente anda é
alex que tem que ser é o sangue
engraçado este andar ainda no que estou
no vácuo e parece aquelas que os frangos
no vácuo à espera que alguém compra um
filho lembra em corte e depois
15 15 inep wheels coisa o advogado
com isso eu estou só com israel não há
mal que nem o meu filho não se preocupe
porque o pai está pior do que tu ou não
não eu já vi este patamar foi no fim do
dia mas podem ter que entrar ali xuxa
mentira nunca viu james bond o 007 jovem
cujo nome não nada pra noite de sexta
feira a equipa conquistou abr isso e
agora esse padrão não superou o lens
superou o méxico os padrões nesta isso
me despedir garrafa quase foi a roda
mista uma bicicleta de montanha e foi
caro foi mil e tal euros r haja mais
gente olha pronto para manter se assim
eu só vi uma pessoa não não não não não
então é isso ai vamos chegar porque com
isso espero que tenham gostado eu gostei
adorei fazer principalmente para o meu
dedo
se quiserem gta também digam aí nos
comentários
eu vou trazer a mesma mesmo que você não
queira mas é mesmo só perceber quantas
pessoas querem e pronto e evidência
então é isso ai q favorito fiquem bem e
até a próxima